you guys we finally got our holiday
merch and we look so good Annie wait you
look really good in Black it's kind of
weird I know it's Sleek it's like the
blonde do you know what it is it's New
York and you miss New York oh I do I got
to say this is one of the most iconic
pictures we've taken in our juicy um
sweatsuits and that was a quickie too
that was a quickie I know I love that
photo so much it needs to be
commemorated and then this shirt is so
soft it's just like the last round of
merch we did where everyone was loving
it it's like soft and comfy and cozy and
I love this color cuz you know baby blue
makes you look young and adorable so you
guys you can check out all our new merch
at it's TR tuesday.com this is our
favorite merch drop yet and we can't
wait to see you guys tag us we'll repost
you we love our slug so much we can't do
any of it without you and guys you can
wear these to a sluggy
sweater Christmas sweater people need to
throw sluggy sluggy uh part parties slug
party slug sweater party I don't know
about you guys but I'm never taking this
one off I know they're so such a I'm
loving a crew neck too I'm loving baby
blue for like snowstorm you really put
the baby in that baby blue but pink and
green is my favorite combo of all time I
know and it's such a good green look at
our Tong they're all pink I know we're
so cute we have hot pink tongues I like
my little BBL I look like I have in
there too stop wasting money on things
you don't use cancel your unwanted
subscriptions and and manage your money
the easy way by going to Rocket
money.com TR Tuesday that's
rocket.com trash Tuesday rocket
money.com TR Tuesday this show is
sponsored by betterhelp find your bright
spot this season with betterhelp visit
betterhelp.com Tuesday today to get 10%
off your first month that's betterhelp
hp.com SLR Tuesday happy holidays sluggy
happy new merch sluggy I'm so excited I
am on the road I'm going to be in
Houston Texas December 15th to the 17th
I'm going to be in Edmonton Canada
January 19th and 20th I'll be in Denver
Colorado in February and I'll be in DC
at the comedy Loft in March a lot of
dates being added so go to Annie
letter.com shows I also have my Annie
wooden friend show uh December 21st at
The Comedy Store get tickets now hi
slugs tomorrow night Wednesday December
6th I will be live at The Comedy Store
doing my show check it out get tickets
at Esther on i.com and then I'll see you
guys in January for my rescheduled San
Jose show uh January 7th you guys
Welcome to our Ski Lodge episode um but
this hurts my head so I'm not wearing it
and today we have David So joining us
that it was quick I didn't know we were
starting already oh yeah no welcome to
that's how it rolls you're lucky we
weren't rolling without telling start
talking I don't give a Fu I actually am
so glad you told me you were pregnant
cuz I was looking at the belly I was
like damn this [__] kind of let herself
go a little bit that's tight well I'm
glad you found out cuz I'm like
commenting on her tits like really in a
way that's so crazy that is my see that
is the problem with this stage of
pregnancy is it is just like she had a
big meal and is not again I don't want
to make this about me but that's what I
regular look like so I want all of you
to shut the [__] off I have a full foa
on these pants and I don't care what's
what's a 5mon pregnant belly supposed to
look like just like
thatway they're all different and I just
found out I have this is so stupid and
boring but I have an anterior placenta
which means the placenta like planted on
top so I show I'm showing a little less
and like I'll feel the kicks not as soon
so your insult was even worse I know my
bad you want you want a you want a boy
or a girl it's a girl oh so you already
know I I when that's what I wanted well
what do you want you just got married I
I don't give a [__] like as long as he's
alive at that point give me a breather I
mean I feel like like nowadays almost
all my friends do uh the the the shot
thing where the [__] thing what do
you call it IVF IVF yeah shot do he
think it's a shot David that [__] thing
where they get shot I like how
disrespectful you are you're the best
you're the best can I tell you something
about David he's like look at your fat
ass [__]
poking can I tell you something about
David by the way this nose left no no is
leaky and it's there's nothing I can do
about it I cannot take it off for a
couple minutes my nose is snowing with
not cocaine but can I tell you something
about this [__] right here he is
the
meanest the meanest
person I have ever met and the upside
though is I can send him the worst [__]
on the internet and nothing phases it he
never flinches he's just like yep yep
the worst [__] Annie are you wearing
this the whole time no no no I'm taking
it off I promise your birthday pick
though was so [__] funny hey dude
it's on my birthday try to be nice to me
what do you what do you think she had
this birthday
photo where her [__] left eye would
look like it was whispering to her right
eye and she was crossy
wait do meing operat I love this he did
you pretty early on no you're
pregnant I got to leave you alone that's
the
wor we had to do like a pillow fight the
other I was like I can't I would be
punting if she wasn't pregnant I would
have punted her across the [__] room
I would have sued you she would have
sued me no no there would have been a
lawyer involved but I would have cared
for me how how tall are you I'm only 5T
tall my and doesn't it sound like she's
lying and it's like so I'm I definitely
am concerned it's not going to fit no
her [__] is huge don't worry is that
you're going to are you are you married
as well I'm engaged oh okay oh we block
that's insane we've been together for we
call it webblock because her toes are we
she's a creature that would be really
weird if my toes were webbed and I can't
swim like that would be so sad how how
tall is your husband he oh your uh
fiance he's 5'9 I think I think she
can't tell she doesn't have a good
reference everyone looks very yeah I did
realize like every guy's tall to me and
that is a privilege that I have David
what are your thoughts on Long
engagements I don't like I mean how long
Esther how long you guys been in Gag for
a long time six years damn dude you
should have left him a while ago h no
I'm problem like that wait how long were
you engaged before you got married [__]
uh [__] I think a year or so did you
guys get engaged immediately start
planning a wedding so we we didn't want
to have a wedding I just had my wedding
uh a couple of months ago and we didn't
want to have we just got court married
for 2 years and then our parents were
giving us [__] that they wanted a
wedding oh so we did a small one for
them and it was really good like I
actually am surprised how much I enjoyed
the wedding well don't you think do you
think cuz you already got married it was
like less pressure too cuz it wasn't as
much of a definitely so when uh there
was a moment where they what do we call
it the thing where you look at your wife
the first look yes I didn't know I
didn't know this thing existed wait I
don't know what what it is first look is
instead of seeing them for the first
time in the um you know down the aisle
when usually the groom will see the
woman for the first time as she's
walking down the aisle now they do the
First Look well they'll they'll have a
moment just the both of them of seeing
her in the dress and seeing each other
in the TU before they walk down the like
to back up yes they do that that is cute
wait I feel like that's embarrassing I
don't want people watch the whole
wedding is embarrassing you got pregnant
before you got married you're done it
doesn't matter yeah I know you're not
worried about embarrassment talk about
embarrassment come on now you go down
your baby's going to be the one your
baby's going to be like and say I
do yeah but that moment too so my wife
asked me you know when you saw when you
turned around you saw me in my wedd just
what did you feel like did you feel
something amaz I told absolutely not
because
well this is why I get in trouble but
it's because the moment that I felt when
we actually got married at court that
was the moment that we were married so
the actual wedding didn't feel like
anything special it might be like the
best situation then because it's so low
pressure at that point yeah the part
though that I was actually surprised it
was a moment where so I've never seen my
parents danc before and so I saw my
parents dance for the first time and I I
was dancing with my mom I saw I've never
danced with my mom before and so when I
had this moment and I was looking at her
it was like this
weird Co core memory that I just created
of watching her smile at me it reminded
me of like I was once a kid and I was
her baby once and when I saw that I was
like holy [__] this this is why we had
the wedding it's for this moment isn't
it crazy like you were her baby I know
and like do you have siblings I have an
older brother yeah he's but you're the
baby isn't that so sweet it's weird
though cuz they considered me the older
brother even though younger I think cuz
my brother's very a little bit
h no I would love brother that be crazy
keep sending videos of your brother to
everyone you're like this is getting
really [__] up like where did you see
this real no these are just family tapes
by the way on that group chat like I'm
very quiet no no no we have a thing we
send each other we have a thing the
internet's look that's not even bad what
the [__] is your guys's threat our thing
is like involves like legs that don't
work and like like draggy leg animals or
people missing Limbs and stuff so war
heroes okay I only watch those video
yeah I only watch it to see what other
people say cuz people are [__] wild
online I would never say this but they
say it online because they have the GU
of like anonymity so the best thing is
when you see a [__] up video and you
don't really care about it but the
comments are [__] hilarious I I do
love me some Tik Tok comments that's
that's basically all of Tik Tok like if
I see the first two minutes of something
that's I know might be interesting I go
straight to the comments even before
finishing the video people are so funny
like I see it's CRA there are comments
that have 50,000 likes I'm like I
couldn't get that many views on a
standup clip if I tried like maybe
that's not true but like they're just
people are so funny that like they're
putting us all out of work I do think
that what's so good about Tik Tok and
like short form internet stuff is like
it's letting everyone just throw
themselves out there and it's I mean
they do get made fun of a lot but it's
like it is pretty amazing like people
are just singing they're doing
everything they want but you guys like
you guys as Comics will never get
replaced by Tik Tok comments and stuff
like that because there's the
performance aspect yeah how many times
have you seen people on the YouTube on
YouTube Tik Tok whatever they all try to
go into your space and then what happens
you have to perform to a live
crowded you know I mean and you have to
stick to the things that you say that's
true but I wouldn't I would still stand
by that those comments are funnier than
anything stand comedian have you ever
had someone comment on one of your
things and you're like I'm actually
adding that like I posted a picture of
my mom years ago and someone wrote your
mom looks like Austin Powers and I was
like that's so [__] up because she
looked in that picture she looked
exactly like Austin Powers and I was
like and we're taking that one do you
feel that in this space because uh you
know with the whole podcasting thing and
everything else has it helped your guys
a standup a lot it help ticket sales
yeah or do you think like our
performance or just like bantering back
and forth or do you ever like say
something on a pod and then you're like
oh I'm going to bring that onto the
stage yes definitely yes that like cuz
it's just getting ideas and thoughts out
and then I'm like oh wait yeah maybe
I'll let's see if that'll work later on
stage or the worse is when you're
working on a bit and then the topic
comes up and you have to be like uh I do
this on stage like so you don't look
like you're like I know doing a bit in
conversation cuz you guys could just
Workshop things as you as you continue
to talk right some of the funniest
moments happen here and if you just he's
looking at you like you're going to do
stand up again I feel like you can
you're little enough for
that can I say that word I mean this is
going to be a bleeper this episode one
of my favorite moments was when um you
know I've known David for a really long
time how by the way tiger belly yeah
tiger belly I did um JK a couple times
oh JK a couple times that's right yeah
yeah yeah and then um this is when I was
just getting back into working out again
and I was like really not necessarily
like feeling myself so I went into the
gym with like some oversized hoodie
oversized sweatpants and I saw David and
I know that he saw me but he didn't say
hi to me for like the first 20 minutes I
was there and that's not my fault
because you look like a trans athlete so
I had no idea she's buff as [__] no I
know she's so [__] her thighs are
like really a crazy thing no but he
finally like 20 minutes in he was like
what the Kaa like hi he just didn't
recognize you yeah he was like who's
that hot ass dude but I like the idea of
you just not talking to
her that's like so funny just not talk
to your friend there's an addition to
this because I was talking to our buddy
Nick he's a personal trainer and then I
was like yo is that Kila I could [__]
tell he like you couldn't tell it was I
was Bull it was bu Gua well I saw your
back your back is huge she is crazy I
legit thought you were a dude I have a
question yeah and maybe after post birth
we can do like a push-up off between you
and Esther I want I want the strongest
and the weakest to push up off and just
see what the difference is what is the
purpose of that can I ask humiliate you
okay that's my thought I just wanted
check are you not athletic she has a NE
she is because she's a dancer and she
she's good at Pilates I look I'm not
made of muscle like Kila I'm just not
but I especially this right now I am
very it's hard being prant well all of
your energy is going into a living being
yeah but Esther I think has some stories
about a neck thing is there a chance I'm
in more shape than you like can I do
more push-ups than you I mean if you'd
like to try I would love
it I I I would never listen I love to be
proven wrong so I and I would love I
would love it here's why here's why you
might have the edge because push-up it's
really hard for people like me with
really long Limbs and I'm also like much
heavier right so I always think like
it's the same thing with like bench
press when I see like short shorter
dudes with shorter limbs like Bobby
could probably like bench all day with
his old T-Rex distance it has to go
right but it's true though like people
you know for example when people do like
Sumo deadlifts right usually shorter
stockier people that that movement is so
short for people like us when we it's
like look how far the bar is that's what
I'm saying I don't work out anyways but
you know I was like looking at your body
I was like is he secretly ripped under
there if I did no I used to be really no
but you are you're you're in good shape
but I was just I was like okay how much
Sumo Li are we doing I hate weight
training I [__] ha why you have to
have the fun trainer my trainer is so
fun it's just boring as [__] I'm telling
you because when I do it without my my
friend Lacy trains me and it's like it
is the most fun I've ever had we're
chatting and then the workouts over yeah
but he's like an incredible like
kickboxer I don't know incredible that
was say that give my ass I'm telling you
David like you know like I watch like a
lot of MMA right that's something that
we have in common like dude there's a
there are a lot of people who train and
don't naturally have that like Rhythm or
that coordination like you just have it
I think also it's just because I I have
like severe ADHD so like when I get into
a hobby I hone in super [__] hard and
then you drop out and then if I'm done
with it I move on so even like
kickboxing that first year I remember
well she was my girlfriend at the time I
would just go to a tennis court and then
use the lines and practice every [__]
day like a maniac as as if I was going
to go to the UFC but I just don't like
not being at least somewhat decent at
something in case somebody says some
[__] you know cuz it bothers me for some
reason but after I get to a point where
it's like oh I could go into a class and
train with people and nobody would say
anything and I'm done with it and I move
on you could probably like become the
best ballet dancer on Earth if you
wanted to with that install you me why a
ballet dancer of you're saying no I
think you're right because you have that
natural coordination well just the fact
that he's the it's the dedication and
the discipline that I'm hearing I'm like
ballet needs you and your body did you
do ballet I did that was like my my
thing and that's it's my favorite thing
about dance and ballet which I miss and
it does not apply to comedy at all was
like if you just practice the exact
moves and the exact like over and over
again you will get better it's like math
what does your feet look like they're
gorgeous they're very cute after ballet
yeah because I didn't do point for many
years and I wasn't I was never feel your
feet are so little that they didn't
what's a difference what's the
difference in doing Point like what does
that mean like point is like when you
see them on their toes and people think
that it's like this brutal thing it's
it's such a myth it's not like you can
put in jelly pads and like um they put
Lamb's wool and you shape your shoe to
your foot it's never that painful like
if you're blistering and getting your
feet all bruised and beaten up you're
probably doing something wrong or you're
in the pros and you're dancing like 12
hours a day like that's I'm getting like
a craving for you to get back into dance
I love when you dance when you dance
it's like one of my favorite things I
was fully dancing
until the sperm at the egg but maybe but
maybe that's going to be like your mommy
me time dancing I'm going to be a dance
I'm a dance mom they said it's a girl I
said I'm a dance mom goodbye like that's
I'm going to you don't understand I'm
quitting com I'm opening a dance studio
like I'm going all the way with this ABY
Lee whatever you have no idea what's
coming did you want to make dance a
career originally yeah I was yeah I
majored in dance in college um for my
were your parents supportive of
that who know who know what are parents
supportive of that's what that's a
question I'd like to know like anyone in
the room had a parent that said hey yeah
that's a great idea my dad with comedy
my mom not my mom she sent me an article
about Jerry Seinfeld saying how hard
comedy was I was like okay [__] your
parents I mean support me now what are
you talking about they dance they gave
me one dance the first time I ever dance
with my mom my dad smiled once he just
took it right away and just w walk away
I don't know my parents didn't ever
support anything that I did it wasn't
like it's not because they're hateful
people they just have a path that they
think is the most successful and what is
that which is just a stable job right so
like for them they had this business and
they still work at the business and it's
hard [__] work what is it uh they own
a black beauty supply store so oh wow
they they've done that for years they
still have it now my mom has never
complained about work but she knows how
hard it is to just worry about your next
patient cuz we grew up super [__]
they just don't want you to experience
this feeling and they saw your add they
went oh godamn it they didn't even know
what it was they just me stupid
all got me dumb where did you grow up I
grew up in Sacramento oh wow yeah
Sacramento California so when uh you
know my parents didn't understand these
things I didn't know I had ADHD I kind
of did but I just got it checked
recently by an actual physician and even
then I I was in denial right cuz I my
friend got diagnosed we had like the
same Tendencies so I went to go talk to
a doctor and and then immediately I was
like hey I'm only getting this test
because my friend told me I should but
I'm pretty sure I don't have this and
they go okay why don't you feel like you
have it I was like cuz when I get into a
hobby I can focus really hard to the
point where nothing else matters she
goes sweetie that's a clear side of I
was like what the [__] that's the best
part of it yeah I didn't know that are
you um are you on medication no I don't
want to uh and I you know we spoke and
then she was saying like well you know
you're high functioning right you're you
clearly can function your everyday life
is perfectly fine but if you have this
need to like complete a task that you
need to get done then maybe you could
take something it's not Aderall there's
this other thing that's a lot weaker
that she was I can't remember the name
but I just decided to just be very
adamant about remembering one thing
throughout my day which is a task Lisk
yeah so if I look at the task Lisk and
it says get these things done by the end
of the day I just have to clear out the
task list so I cuz I forget all the time
like even yesterday I got pissed at
myself because I had to go get the line
laundry out from the garage and every
time I walked to the garage I saw
something and I got distracted I know
it's so crazy it took me 6 hours I'm
late here every day it's like there
there's some I'm like guys I don't know
how to explain to you how much time I
give myself I go to my car I forget five
things I have to go back up then I
forget something I go back up and I go
what did I forget like I have to like
sit there for like feeling of like
opening the fridge but not like
forgetting that you did that just 30
seconds ago and you're looking for the
same do you walk into a room go did I
walk into this room all the time but
like with a fridge thing I don't know if
this why was I here what am why was I
born with a fridge thing I just opened
the fridge thinking that something will
miraculously something new will
miraculously appear no one I think what
that is like ADHD is your brain is
moving faster than your body right so
like you your brain had a thought your
body's following it and then your brain
is to the next thought and you forget
why you were there in the first place
that's it's a weird thing I forgot how
she was explaining it to me once again I
have ADHD so I don't remember [__] she
say and it's so funny when they assess
you like they could tell you like you're
drifting immediately so it was something
along the lines of and once again I'm
just paraphrasing but it's like when
people do like remedial task right if
you need to get it done there's a
certain level like an endorphin hit that
you get when you complete a task but
someone with ADHD it just doesn't happen
we get nothing from it and so
immediately it shifts off and a lot of
people confuse ADHD with high anxiety
cuz high anxiety you're just hyper
voided well they go hand in hand too
yeah they can go hand in hand I think
well kind of what you were saying about
how you were like you were getting
pissed at yourself it's like I think
that's the worst part of ad is like you
get mad at you like lash yourself for it
it's like and the best part is that you
can do this hyperfocus and you can be so
creative and it is like it has its like
like like Dr Drew says assets and
liabilities like there are really some
upsides to being like high hard on your
partner too if they don't understand oh
my God are you kidding me I dated a guy
Bobby Bobby has ADHD oh my God so much
so that all over the place I know I was
like Bobby how'd you get up there and
your pants are down on medication
because like that's the reason why he
could never reply to text mess which one
do you take ad or ad all and he has high
anxiety too at the same time doesn't he
very yeah I it was like night and day
from the moment he started taking it it
was almost like he was just aware of his
surroundings almost like he could be
present because before that his like
Soul was here his body was here and it
just felt like these two no that cuz we
did a photo shoot for our movie a couple
months ago and I was like I'm like
spending quality time with Bobby he
listens right we're like hanging out it
was so fun I'm telling you this if we
had if he had started medication like
earlier on in a relationship rather than
the tail end like we probably would have
still been together because so much of
don't say this to me you know how hard I
have a time I'm having with you guys she
still wants us you still want how long
have you guys been broken up now almost
two years damn girls two years yeah I
thought it was like what the hell you
talking about two years it's almost as
long as your engagement God damn Let It
Go they're done D [__] roasted that's
just gone I don't know what my problem
is I like it's cuz they're really fun
together yes they're fun but they still
are fun together that's the thing yeah
that's true even though we all know we
think it's very unhealthy but we're
still we support we support that they
don't agree with us and you know what
like till you turn blue in the face like
him and I will probably never like leave
each other in that way in like a
friendship way how how is that though
when you guys date right because that's
very odd are you kidding me I took his
girlfriend
like around aahu did you like dun a
second did you like dunk her and hold
her under for a second she was really
sweet but Bobby like was sick she's like
suck like I did
[__] and we all know the answer is no
he start speaking his tongue after he
came you [__] ho that's my next
that's my biggest fantasy for this year
is drowning you the next time you're in
Hawaii okay let me tell you something I
just called you crossy once that's it
that's all I did he's like I think it's
so much more than
that you took his the girl that he's
dating out he got sick and he was like
she he got sick and he he was like K
like I feel bad like she hasn't really
seen the beach he still very dependent
on you then huh yeah but that's Al
that's a me issue but then it was if he
had said that and he wasn't sick um I
probably would have been like no dude
it's your [__] job you got to go do
that I don't know you're right I I got
them both
IV I did you stabbed her
I got them IVs in their hotel room and
then I took her around the island I
would love to make good use of my ex's
the way Bobby is able to do that with
you yeah I think um there is a level of
like endless gratitude that I have for
him and that lives very deep inside me
so I always feel very much like indebted
to him still that that's why when you
told me this I was like that is
beautiful like you guys are a family and
you're helping but then family that
[__]
yeah right we all do that right guys
wait wait can can I tell you something
something super unhealthy that I did
other unhealthy things I've done the
last time we had dinner I went home and
I sleuthed and I googled EV every single
one of your ex-girlfriends oh my god
dude what' you think no we I I sent her
quite a few too cuz I had to go why
because were were you talking about it
at dinner yeah we were just talking
about [__] like crazy stories of
like easy you know and I had like I get
fixated I'm like I need to like have a
face to this story so then I have this
like really deep urge to just find them
all I think that's good that's good of
the worst girlfriends I've ever had were
Filipino yeah this is why I needed to
find them cuz he was like is that how it
came up you just looked at her and
you're like reminded me of some times
they were just so mean they just so
aggressive and mean and just too
hypersexual dude I just didn't like it
hypersexual oh my god well you got one
you got one out of three what is that
what is it with like Filipino girls in
just [__] I think their hips are just
ready for it before I moved to LA before
I decided that I was just going to drop
out of college and just come here this
girl she we were hooking up and I didn't
know that she was still married but she
told me they were divorced and so it's
like don't put me in this position so
this is what happened so I'm chilling
her husband confronts me and he was like
hey you're [__] my wife were you
doing kickboxing yet no dude glasses I
like 200 something like 280 lb or [__]
he was like you're [__] my wife and I
probably saw he's like you were [__]
my wife that's how he said it but he he
was like you of all people and then he
killed himself yeah he just beat himself
up he Tyler dired
himself yeah then he came he's like
you're [__] my wife I was like who's
your wife and he said her name I'm like
you guys are divorced he goes we're
still together he's like we're divorced
you're like everything's so confused
everything was so well like hey you
can't get mad at me I didn't know she
told me you guys were divorced so that's
something you guys should go have was he
aggressive was he trying to like scrap
he was angry but then I was
substantially larger than him so how did
he find out I don't know he asked people
friends or whatever I I think he found
out from one of her friends because she
was asking me uh if I was dating her and
I was like and I denied it because she
you know we just started fooling around
at the point at that point you were
still at the lie about it face were you
in love with this girl like you were
catching feelings no we were just
hooking up so it wasn't anything like
that and then when that happened she
went to go she goes well we're separated
but we're not legally it's like that's
not what he was saying he's saying that
y'all are together together you know
what I mean but then this gets even
weirder too so they started having
marital issues because and what I found
out through a friend of mine who's a sex
therapist there's two reasons why people
get divorced the most sexual reasons and
uh financial reasons so there's was
sexual he had a micro penis oh so he was
really sad when he saw you so he was
like how did you find out so we found
out cuz she would talk to me about her
ex-husband and then she so so funny we
were at a Starbucks and then she gets
her Starbucks Couer where we're talking
I was like well what happened between
you and your ex-husband which they
weren't ex-husband wife at the time she
goes well like sexually we don't match
up he actually has a micropenis I didn't
know what a microp penis was so I was
like hey don't [__] roast the guy
like that you know but I didn't know
also like [__] you must have been okay
with it cuz you married his ass well
there you go and I think like so she she
I grabbed her Starbuck I was like I'm
going to put and your [__] have to say
yes guys your heart and your [__] so I
I pulled the the straw all the way down
and I was like you stop at the size of
his erect penis and it was like this big
and I was shocked and I started Googling
it and then the Howard Stern Show came
up where he had bunch of people with
microp penises and I'm like this is
insane I didn't know that this was is
really a Pioneer wasn't
it it was he just had them all lined up
and I just went through this like rabbit
hole of micropenises which my Google
search was weird as [__] at the time but
they jerking off girlfriends they were
like
salivating before I left Sacramento too
she pulled this crazy [__] where she
said that she was pregnant by you or him
by by me before I left yeah and I was
like there's no [__] way dude my pull
out game is so [__] good you're lying
funny we were just talking about this um
in the last episode pulling out Works
pulling out works if your guy is good
you got to trust the man I don't trust
my fance it depends right it depends on
if the guy is just you know he's playing
with fate if he's doing it right before
he's about to come then you're pretty
much [__] at that point right but you
got to pull out and then finish the rest
yourself there's got to be at least 15
seconds of jerking off I think if you're
a good puller outer right if you're
responsible 15 or just like you know 15
I think she said right not 50
you're that's why we're like oh you if I
turn the TV on like okay a very weird
moment though for me at least there's
always that point where a man is like
you know finishing ejaculating and I
don't know like I just look like I just
I'm like stop looking [__] you're
making me nervous is that something that
takes that's the worst when you do take
them out of it and you're like oh boy
here I'm just looking right it's like
what am I supposed to it's already dry
now you're putting the dry one back in
you're looking at him do this yeah yeah
so like why is that bad when he's coming
are you just look right I just look I
think that's why would hot don't you I
go like
this well what are you supposed to do
like look away like I don't know but
like they might like that they might
like
I like that I'm getting well clearly
there's no pull out game at this point
but like if he did pull out what what
what happens I'm not allowed to get into
intimate details of my
respected um I think that might be worse
too it's like Dave what's worse talking
about you or those other on being came
on by other men I feel like you could
get your I feel like you could get your
exes not to go back too far but you
could get your exes to do stuff for you
I think you've you've left I think
you've left your exes in a very positive
good way no we're all All My Exes speak
so highly except my high school ex who
blocked me on everything and I wrote a
movie about him but um well that's fine
you're showing
him your face check the show times
[__] at a theater near you that is
honestly you should have the premiere at
the theater closest to his house Annie
you got to stop building this I'll come
with you come with you can we give David
some context yeah did he do something
bad he just okay like just he's the only
one that truly rejected her I no they've
all rejected me but but truly I'm just
upset I was obsessed with my high school
breakup for a really long time um and
then I you know was texting him and then
he blocked me and then I would drive
past his house for years oh what the
[__] yeah I know what's wrong with you a
lot a lot of stuff wait what's going on
with that she Longs for childhood so he
said no and you're like I'm going to see
you
more how [__] that work I think it's
just it was the like the first time
anyone in my life was ever like like cut
me off and because it is so strongly
associated with the most magical time
for me in my life like high school doing
musical theater all you know all this
stuff having sex whatever you do in high
school it just like I I short yeah I it
messed me up in such a way you just
didn't have access to that part and it
was like he just cut you off out of
nowhere cold well he dumped was oh yeah
okay he dumped me um and I think also
there was a lot of how it went down you
know we worked at Johnny Rockets
together and then he start I got him the
job there and then he started dating
another girl who worked there so I just
there was all these things of the story
where I felt like I did this to myself
cuz I got him the job at Johnny Rocket
so when you were stalking him what did
you think the outcome was going to be
after like I'm really curious I think I
just really wanted to like accidentally
see him
you
know while taking the garage she talks I
slowly start moving
this did you
want did you want to see him or did you
want him to see you because you felt
like hey look at me now I that's a
really good question but definitely like
sometimes when my dad would drive me
past his house and my okay this story is
getting way worse I love how your dad is
in on it so I just love like a father
daughter
team the least the less healthy the
sometimes my dad would slow down I'd be
like no no no keep going keep he's he's
a troll your dad a little bit right was
he trying to [__] with you so I didn't
want to be caught or seen but maybe
you're right like I you know what I
think that is part of it too that what
you're getting at is I want to be like
look at what you lost but it's like he
can watch TV just like that dud do it
just like that by the way he can watch
he's going to definitely miss out on
movie is really going to be the it is
the Moment the movie is the moment but
also can I just say something it's
like you what you just explained and D
you made a movie out of it but it is the
perfect quintessential High School
experience to have like your boyfriend
that you're like having sex with did you
lose your virginity to him yeah yes so
you lose your virginity to him you're in
the musicals you're living your best
life musicals was big you're living your
best life for him to dump your ass and
then you work together and then he hooks
up that is like uh that's like you lived
the whole high school movie yeah yeah
that's like Sweet Valley High it really
is I Love Sweet Valley oh my god did you
guys have a conversation I to break up
and he told you why no she knows oh see
that's why dude you didn't you didn't
get a definitive why like he didn't say
like hey this is why we're not going to
work out he didn't no and was that
[__] you up a little bit maybe I need
to maybe let call him on someone else's
phone you still you still don't know now
should we call him on someone else's
phone I will go to jail do you know that
I will go to jail if you had a birth in
jail oh my God story sequel oh your
kid's going to be Tupac that's [__]
dope awesome so wow so does is it
concluded now though if you see him
you'll be okay I think now I'm feeling
pretty good about it I'm feeling would
you break down and start crying no I
think if I saw him I would be I would
try my best to be normal but I do think
word has gotten back to him can you
reenact it with okay I want to see this
because everybody says that but they
never they're never like this what did
he look like like my current fiance oh
really okay that's so cute you're just
Rec but you got the better version what
does he do now do you know what his job
is the way if you knew how like it's I
can't even talk about what his life
became cuz it's too mean like I upgraded
times 10 million like he just sounds
like you're still in love sounds like
you still want to [__] him though huh am
I right sounds like kilus
type but you know for me one of the
hardest things I still haven't gotten
over is I cheated on a boy when I was 17
his name is Bradley vandercam and he was
my first boyfriend in colge he a [__]
murderer was a Canadian he kill Natalie
H that's Vander
slute um but he was a Canadian swimming
sensation he swam at UNLV we were
freshmen together and I cheated on him
and he knew about it he found out but
you know what he did that really [__]
me up he didn't accept my apology and he
didn't allow me to make amends and that
for some reason like is really hard for
me to um kind of like reconcile with
because I really want to apologize
because he was like
but he just wouldn't have it blocked me
on everything we never same as you like
won't take my friend requests won't
reply to my messages of saying like hey
if that was something that like [__]
you up cuz we were young right like
things that happen when you're young
really do stick how old were you at the
time I was 17 oh was super young yeah
yeah and I think it [__] him up and I
just I'm so sorry about it even to this
day and I he's just like I don't think
he probably didn't think about me but
like it's hard when they don't accept
the apology it like kind of cool don't
you respect it kind of totally respect
Todd's someone that doesn't like he
never is friends my fiance never is
friends with his exes like he doesn't
like he's not mean to them or anything
but he just doesn't like it's like why
yeah he just doesn't keep that
connection cuz he's just like you know
yeah and it kind of inspired me to stop
like I mean like there's exes that I see
around or whatever it's funny cuz my
ex's current girlfriend is always trying
to be friends with me what I can see and
it's so weird but I remember he always
talks about his ex-girlfriend so he must
bring me up like every day to her he
just has like a loop of like talking
about old stories and so when she sees
me she probably feels like she knows me
really well and I'm like I'm out [__]
good luck God bless you you're so cute
beautiful girl beautiful girl the
problem with what that guy did how he's
not letting you interact with him is
that he's not able to get any closure
probably he's just shutting it out
pushing it down and then probably taking
it out on every woman he meets or he
just I think a crazy [__] dude tring to
rationalize you stalking somebody some
people just some people [__] is going on
with this one dude some people just cut
cords that's what it is I think he is
sorry hold on com in a whole backstory
for somebody she doesn't she's trying to
write her movie now I got it I got the
second ass he's suffering he thinks
about you every day when he's yelling at
his girlfriend yes that's what I think
you cheat on him and he's a [__]
loser how about that dud I honestly
think um I'm going to take what they're
saying because I think he's just
somebody who's healthier probably more
secure and doesn't [__] need my
apology he probably doesn't think about
it but don't you we all meet those guys
we all know those guys or we're friends
with one of those guys that like clearly
has Hang-Ups with women and thinks all
women are [__] and all this stuff and
I don't you think that's like the exact
origin story of that guy no I think
Mommy I think it's like cuz like I
always tell it's from Mommy I always
tell Jules this I'm like look if you're
going to
um break up with a guy like especially
CU she's so young and she's been with
her boyfriend for you know since they
were really young so I was like look you
could potentially dictate how he views
like women from like here on out so I
was like whatever you do like be kind if
you're going to break up
respons not I'll tell you this right
that type of guy that that turns out to
be the hateful woman person isn't the
guy that's dating the person who gets
[__] over in a relationship doesn't
end up being the person that hates all
women they just end up [__] more
women right usually the guy that can't
get a girl ends up like that because
they think that women that they are owed
affection by a woman just because
they're kind to them that's the guy
that're the Prototype that I see
constantly they go oh like nice guys
finish last oh these women don't like me
because they don't know what's good for
them it's like or you're
unattractive no I I was talking to a guy
who's like severely overweight like like
like not going to live long life okay
and he was complaining about how girls
don't like him cuz he's too nice or
whatever but being such a dick about it
and he goes and I go but eventually also
like you can find a woman that's like
that wants like a Kinder guy you know
not that he was exhibiting any of those
behaviors and he goes yeah but then
they're all busted up and all them I'm
like you are a bad guy do push-ups do
push-ups and sit ups this is saying like
their thing is that I'm a nice guy but
you're not you're not and nice guys
don't say I'm a nice guy
exactly they always say like beware of
declarations if he's telling you he's
this he's probably the opposite if he
has to say it out loud he's trying to
convince himself of that fact I had a a
boyfriend who was overweight and said he
would always go I'm such a nice guy
literally me made my mom cry twice his
mother when we were on vacation once he
was screaming at me that he wanted me to
die when I was sick I was like throwing
up his mom heard it the next day she was
like she like pulled me aside and she's
like I want to really apologize I didn't
raise him right she goes I did not teach
him the difference between being being
funny and being mean and he's very mean
and I was like that is a guy who runs
around going I'm so nice why aren't
people dealing I'm nice I am my that's
like big incel energy though it's crazy
it's just a weird thing that uh I think
a lot of young guys do right because
they always think that nice guys finish
last and I don't think that's the case I
think really nice guys always finish
first like they always get nice okay
nice is not over like overgiving nice is
having respect for yourself too cuz I
have friends that are very simpy and
they get really mad when girls are like
put a boundary out for them and they
keep going like why won't they just let
me like because what they're saying is I
need some space I need this to go slower
and you're over sing and then they're
like mad that they're like well I'm so
it's like that's not nice or they just
don't like you that's okay I don't think
it's I I think that I think that it's
not always that I think it really is
like if things are going too fast and
someone's being overboard into it
doesn't feel like it's you they're into
you need to like it seems like they're
just into wanting to be into someone I
see what you're saying I and then it's
like so then you're going like okay I'm
starting to feel an ick I want to just
like slow this down I'm going to give
you a boundary don't call me so much
don't text me so much if they ignore
that it's it is showing that they are
overriding your feelings for also too
sometimes their intention isn't very
clear right so what they'll do is I call
in Korea we call like the church Opa
right so oppa is like the older sibling
and so what they'll do is like they'll
do something in the guise of friendship
but they're really trying to [__] you
right and they'll just be around for the
and they'll just
huh the church Opa Church Opa always
does really strategic yeah so they just
kind of weighed and then let's say this
let's say you're with you break up right
and I slide in I'm like I'm here for you
you guys talk a little more and then you
confide in me but then you confide in me
in a way that because I'm there for you
but not in a sexual way and they go well
nice guys finished last she's like or
you were trying to be sneaky and it
didn't work out and you're with a girl
who's not even in a place to be with
someone right now they're like dealing
with like breaking up with this that's
like that long Conor who doesn't
actually get what he wants at the end
doesn't win the girl at the end but that
is to me like so slithery I hate that
[__] it's it's I think it's a young guy
thing it happens as they get older they
get rid of it because they get more
experience but when you're young it's
just you guys let's talk about rocket
money it's saved my money it saved my
finances it saved your rocket money it
saved everything well it's because I
have ADHD like you and I just do not
remember what I subscribe to and it's
really usually to cancel a subscription
is really hard and Rocket money just
does it for you all in one place um
rocket money is a personal finance app
that finds and cancels your unwanted
subscriptions monitors your spending and
helps you lower your bills all in one
place thank God for Rocket money because
usually when I hear the term rocket
money I think of a rocket I strap my
money to and shoot it into space Oh and
Rocket money by the way they can
negotiate your bills for this is what's
crazy I know people need this this is
like having your own like little Jewish
grandfather who's willing to like do
your dirty work for you up to 20% with
over 5 million users in counting rocket
money has helped save its customers an
average of $720 a year and $1 billion in
total savings so far if you are that
kind of person where money is just kind
of loose and free and you're not
focusing on it because it gives you
anxiety definitely check out rocket
money it will get you on the right path
stop wasting money on things you don't
use cancel your unwanted subscriptions
and manage your money the easy way by
going to Rocket money.com trash Tuesday
that's rocket money.com sltr Tuesday
rocket
money.com TR Tuesday this time of year
can be a lot for many of us it's it's
family it's memories it's triggering
it's traffic it's traffic holiday
traffic it's travel it's ples packed to
the gills it's flying and coach in the
very back it's middle seats ah and if
you're thinking of starting therapy now
is a great time and give better help a
try it's entirely online designed to be
convenient flexible and suited to your
schedule it's very easy you just fill
out a brief questionnaire to get match
with a licensed therapist and switch
therapist which is my favorite part you
can switch therapists at any time for no
additional cost which is something that
can be a little difficult with um
traditional therapy and I need my
therapy to be convenient I need it to be
flexible that is why better help is
where I go find your bright spot this
season with betterhelp visit
betterhelp.com Tuesday today to get 10%
off your first month that's better help
hp.com TR Tuesday there were I
encountered so many church opas when
Bobby and I broke up oh really so many
people who were who I thought were she
was like I'm
ovulating somebody's going to knock me
up I hope it's you well with church Opa
energy at least like people I thought
were like mutual friends or whatever who
if you need a an ear I'm here for you I
do not know that yeah and I think that
there are people always in the sidelines
who you think are very well-intentioned
but who really are just waiting for that
[__] to get thrown in their Direction
you know you got to be a real man like
when your home girls come up they I have
a problem you go well talk to me when
you're healthy and then you then you
move on then you come back go talk I
when you're hot talk to your girlfriends
about this [__] come to me when you
want to have fun right is that what you
do when um Marielle has um issues you
think like okay this is a conversation
we can have or this is something you
should have with your girls always that
and I always tell her this too I go like
I'm like emotions and feelings are great
right but if she wants to have a
conversation about this white puppy that
she saw on Instagram she goes hey babe
watch this I'm like hey wrong person go
call your best friend what the [__]
do because you know I the like but she
now she knows she goes oh he's not going
to be because she's not going to get
what she wants from me which is oh my
God this is amazing well this is so cute
but why not David because it's [__]
but but you know like can't you just
like what is it like the gothman study
where they say like the successive
relationship is based on one very major
thing which is if something excites me
and you don't engage even a little bit
with this excitement that there's going
to be some type of contempt between us
tell you read too much [__] all right I
say I'm team David over here because
like I the thing that has made my
relationship so great is like I I have
so many other friends I go to for other
things and like yes I think there if I
am really excited about something that
is very important to me yes I think he
should be at least you know give a
little bit but if it's a video or you
know don't you think this outfit is cool
I don't know I don't I just think that
it's helped me to diversify whereas when
I was younger and stupider I wanted to
get all my needs met from one person and
that was not yeah I see what you're
saying one of my biggest fights with
Bobby is because I saw a red tail hawk
and I'm really into like birds and stuff
right all right fool continue okay I'm
out I'm dumping your ass right now I
completely agree so I love red tail
hawks I'm all right dude can you believe
I saw red I be like [__] we got work to
do can we that's out his
habitat but it's like if no one else you
don't care I'm in bird I can't call you
about the red tail hawk I can't call you
about it I can't call you about it so
now all I have is Bobby and when I pass
a bird I'm like Egret or red tail hog
and then if he doesn't say oh cool babe
I get really upset listen I it's so easy
is the thing yeah we just be like tell
me like to just say that it's easy but
girls are a lot are emotionally
intelligent and you can tell when we're
not interested and it's still going to
[__] you up so Anno it's still going to
[__] you that is so true you exactly so
this is what I'm saying it's better for
you to go elsewhere if it's like this
right you come up we're together and you
go hey I'm about to do this concert in
blah blah blah blah right I don't give a
[__] but I'll be like I'm proud of you
babe you know I'll give you one of those
right wait who can I call about the red
tail
hawk I mean you can call me I might not
answer they will yeah I mean you could I
listen I like if it's attached listen
listen I will I'll be into it if it's
like attached to like if you're like you
know they always remind me of my dad I
think my dad is like if it's like some
like your dad's trying to I into it
listen red tail hawks paragan Falcons
all that other stuff right don't get me
black one of my favorite Birds I like
birds I love corvids corvids are my
favorite an [__] he loves Birds I do
you know it was the way she said it was
just the way she said it was like don't
just assume we like I was like a bird
watcher [__] are kind of cool you have
binoculars in your in your bag is it
crazy I go [__] lie I did ad got in
isn't it crazy though how you can go
from like never caring giving a [__]
about birds to one day just caring so
much about birds or or gardening okay
he's a gardener The Gardener I get
because I would I would I need to talk
to somebody about tomatoes and then you
know she don't want to hear this [__]
but I was like Hey listen I need you to
I'm going to explain to you what these
tomatoes are for 10es can I just tell
you what the answer to all this is yes
it's Reddit go to Reddit there's a
Reddit for I don't like Reddit there's
too mean no but you don't go to the mean
ones Reddit is supposed to be where you
celebrate the things you like and find
other people that like them not like
hating on everyone hey go on a tomato
Reddit they're mean [__]
they're mean as [__] they all you ask a
question like what are you stupid you
don't look at the almanac well sometimes
yeah know you're right I'm like yo I
don't know about this [__] get mad at me
tell us about tomatoes so I'm I'm not
it's a long diet tribe she's she's GNA
die but I would tell her like hey give
me 10 minutes so I could just tell you
about these heirloom tomatoes that I'm
growing I would go like this five if I
was your right if I go I'll give you
five minutes no 10 is the shortest cuz
it's really 30 so I'm cutting it down by
a third and then she' just be like okay
H she does have to be excited you use
one of those tomato timers what they
have like a tomato shaped timer you just
turn it for 10 minutes those are c i we
got into a fight because I told her that
I don't like waking up too early which I
do now and I just found I'm very
caffeine sensitive so I just cut that
out and now I can sleep but I told her
like I don't want to go on least 5 a.m.
hikes it's just too early in the morning
well tomato season came around 4:00 a.m.
I'm out there I'm out in this [__] just
tending tomatoes and she woke up cuz
she's about to work she looks outside
and I'm tending Tomatoes she turned red
angry she like if I look like a tomato
maybe he'll pay attention to me she's
like you literally told me you can't
wake up to go hiking with me your wife
but these stupid [__] Tomatoes you
wake up every day for I like ADHD baby I
don't know I don't know what I kind of
want to defend you a little bit in
saying that like I think this is
something you do for yourself like this
is something that's very meditative this
is something that like for who knows why
makes you feel some type of like
internal peace it's my mom my mom does
like gardening stuff and I feel like
that's what we connect on isn't that so
cool when you feel like your parents
like threw you doing don't you Garden I
I did and this you kill them huh no it's
like I planted tomatoes and green
peppers and the citrus trees and then
they all came due and I was pregnant and
I couldn't have any of them and I'm just
like really pissed can you tell the
story again about the branches what oh
it's my favorite please in Co like I was
doing a lot of gardening and I I got
really into mint and so I would and
pruning you know so I would every day i'
would go outside prune all my little
herb gardens whatever and then you know
I would just like let the the sticks the
whatever excess like on the floor the
ground whatever you call it outside and
the ground whatever you call the floor
it's Mom
brain and then one day Dave and I were
out that's my fiance we were outside
together and he was like what do you
think happens like when you prune to all
the things out that you leave like the
dead pieces and I was like oh my God
like it's actually really amazing like I
do I cut them out and then the birds
come and take them away and Dave was
like that's not Birds it's me picking up
your garbage she thought birds were
coming you should talk to her about
birds more you didn't know what you
thought they were make you were giving
them like Nest are great right did you
know that you're not a Disney
cartoon you're a human being what I'm
not sure you're
correct I think she's the bird are
coming to pick up your branches I don't
know you every morning you're like my
life is great like what is going on I
know he didn't leave you after that no
but it came up a lot for a while the
amount of respect I would have lost for
my partner would been like wow that's so
cute though I see this kind of cute also
it's so funny to relate to your like
waking up early for your Tomatoes like
Dave my fiance will he will sleep till 1
100 p.m. any day every day and then
there's always like a time of year where
suddenly he's waking up at 10:00 a.m.
and I'm like oh my it's football season
like he will wake up for football then
nothing else do you um does it bother
you that he wakes up late or do you not
care no I don't mind I actually I you
know what I I used to be when we first
started dating the girlfriend that would
lay in bed and wait and then you realize
no just get up and start your day I'm
the opposite I'm like just start
talking don't even wait for them to open
their eyes just start talking and
eventually they'll hear you I was with
someone who didn't wake up till 6:00
p.m. some days right cuz he would play
video games till like 9: in the morning
and the video game thing is crazy cuz
they are having so much fun no he's
locked in they're literally having the
best time of their life and you can't be
a part of it I cannot not only can I not
be a part of it but when it involves
like screaming play no games like
screaming and like he plays with other
people like Todd it actually is precious
Todd talks to all of his his high school
friends every night they're playing
games it's like so amazing it's
incredible and they're just making fun
of one other guy they went to high
school the entire time they're do voice
H perfect example Bobby can play 16
hours straight with no breaks and be
really hyperfocused it's hard to sleep
though when you do that cuz your brain
you're getting yeah yeah yeah when it's
actually time to wind down like he can't
I can't play games man gam boring as
[__] I think it's boring too sit there
and you stare at screen all day it feels
like the energy I'm putting into it I
would much rather be putting into
something else that's more like
productive for me there was a game I
forgot what it was it was like in the
cowboy world where they would just like
farm and [__] they're like oh I'm like
what did I played this game and I just I
was tending to my horses I went on walks
I was like in the game that's what
you're playing accomplished yeah I did a
whole day of farming like no you sat on
your ass I'm like shocked no but it's
true like um Bobby play stard Valley and
that's all that that he does farm he
like tends to meanwhile I'm starving
where's my food like when I see people
play shooting game I get it you I mean
it's exciting like the endorphins are
high but when you told me that you just
farmed in a game like what what's the
objective of this I don't understand
well look like I shouldn't talk so much
[__] because I've never like been a
gamer but I am like the top five like
Tetris player in Los Angeles is that
legit or you just titled that yourself
you want to look at my phone was like I
did it once hold on a second I'm like
I'm like a Tetris freak what does that
mean I'm so fast I have a that actually
makes sense with your personality you
are good at like figuring things out
what I cannot do is parallel park it's
so weird right cuz I'm really good with
Tetris and space and like figuring where
go very fast people are watching you
when you're parallel parking no I don't
know what it is it's just I hate to say
this because I hate The Stereotype but
there is something to do with you think
that lazy eye no you just hold on you
guys are wrong about the one lazy eye
they're both one eye one eye is parking
and the other one is your eyes have to
be parallel to parallel park no you just
need practice I you can learn it's a
trick there's like a way you look at it
in the mirror and it works I mean if the
space is big enough but if it's like
tight they cannot do car too I'm telling
you guys like somehow spatially I'm a
genius and really stupid at the same
time I don't know man I hate driving in
general I like I also don't understand
why people love cars so much I I still
can't wrap my head what kind do you have
I have a RAV four I have a RAV four Prim
I love RAV fours I'm obsessed with RAV
fours I so the Rav 4 Prime goes almost
as fast as a model y okay so but like I
don't care about like how fast are you
going to go here like you're in traffic
all the time that is true my thing about
cars it just needs to get me from point
A to point B and so and then also gas I
completely agree like a car is
transportation it's not my personality
it's nothing else and also what's the
point of a fast car you have to go the
speed limit am I the only one I've never
gone to speed Li in my life you're GNA
you're going to get hurt do I have to do
traffic school yes by the 18th somehow I
don't know how it's going to happen yeah
but guys love cars like they'll show you
their the the value of them as a male is
based on their
car cool I think it's really cool if you
like cars like if you work on cars
you're you worked on cars with your
family it was like you know how
everything works like I think that's
awesome because it's very similar to
like gardening right like especially if
you're a mechanic and it's something
that you are kind of fixing fixing up
from like class I'm talking about people
who just buy a car weird well cuz also
it's like it is cars lose their value
immediately they're not like it's it's
it's how many people have like are you
trying to have like the only be the only
person with the specific car then
everyone knows who you are driving it's
weird I like the outdoor cars like
people fix it up they do all this cool
stuff with it it's like a project but
that you buy a car and you're like this
is my nice car I'm like all right cool
[__] story yeah it's embarrassing on
my first date with Dave I'll never
forget like we walked to his car and I
knew at that time he had a good job he
you know I see a 2002 Honda Civic I'm
like I love this man he is not spending
frivolously he's not some cool La guy
with an Audi like it was just such a
like a hot is he like a 70-year-old
Chinese man
is this
dude he just like squatting with a
cigarette in his mouth and a missing too
who the [__] is this
guy the idea of Dave with just a front
tooth missing is so funny to me see I
thought that too when I first met Bobby
he um his car had obviously disgusting
on the inside it probably had like big
balls of mold and fungus and everything
else but it had cans of Red Bull
everywhere and I was like you know I
really like this guy he's not
pretentious he's showing me who he is
also he drives a Prius with like [__]
bullet holes and like it's all dented in
and [__] so I was like I like that he
doesn't spend frivolously wrong wrong
not on that just not on the car but
other things he did so I was like you
know might I like Bobby's car now and I
like that I know it's a little trashed
oh the the Audi I like that it's nice
and is this true I heard this like myth
when I first started standup in La at
The Comedy Store that Bobby one time
like lost his car and couldn't find it
yeah and then just bought a new one not
not couldn't find it um he it broke down
on the freeway and instead of calling
triaa he just like left it there and
then bought a new car he also rented a
car from Enterprise this like he's like
blacklisted at Enterprise he rented a
car for a whole year they had to like
reported stolen all that I think he like
racked up like $25,000 or something like
that and he just because he couldn't his
ADHD didn't allow him to just return it
there's a part of too inconvenient loves
that part of Bobby the most and it is a
part I'm working on changing but I
admire how Bobby will just get himself
out of something he'll just go how
quickly can I get myself out yes okay so
he he we were I don't know I think we
had rescued a dog somewhere but it was
all the way on like the west side and he
backed up into a car his legs did work
he backed up into a car and um the
family or the the owner of the the car
saw the whole thing happen and he was
like he get bobby gets out the car and
he was like I don't know I don't want to
do paperwork here's $1,000 it was a very
tiny dent and the guy's like yeah cool
like he just wants to get out of it so
fast that's his anxiety though for sure
yeah it's anet he doesn't want to be
inconvenient like if there's he always
says like if there's paperwork I don't
want it and he just want I do have that
same thing though but then like a part
of me doesn't like that about myself so
I confront it all the time it's like I
hate this [__] but David you're a
businessman like you have a lot on your
plate like you're a legitimate
entrepreneur that's like when kids like
ask like cuz I have very high anxiety
too but I just I just don't like that
about myself like it just bothers me so
much cuz my dad hated when I was a kid I
couldn't even order food like at like a
McDonald's it would give me like an
anxious breakdown too many options oh
God my dad used to beat my ass cuz I
couldn't do cuz he it's not manly you
know what I mean now you kickbox now
pops say some [__] now you on the Dance
Floor I'm stealing your girl but you
know what happened like I found out my
dad has crazy anxiety so he hated seeing
this quality in his son that he had in
himself and I saw this at the wedd
wedding so my dad was a pastor right
he's supposed to do a speech in Korean
for the Korean family members before
this happens he comes up to me and he's
like ah I don't think I could do it I
was like well you already said you would
and this is important because they don't
speak English so could you it's just 3
minutes you said it was easy he actually
volunteered yeah it's like great oh he
comes back and he goes hey so um your
mom's sick I think we have to go home
and I look at him and I'm like are you
[__] lying to me I was like are you
lying right now and he's like no she's
really sick I was like cool and my mom
comes over she's all having a good time
I'm like so you're sick she say no I'm
not sick I was like Dad says you're sick
so you want to go home is that true she
looks at me pissed she goes back I just
see them yelling in the back my dad
comes back he goes so your Mom feels
good now I think I'm good to this speech
I was like the [__] is going on he was
having a nervous breakdown before he was
going to do the speech and he has high
anxiety I had no idea my dad has the
same thing my dad would like we call it
[__] you Stan because my dad would it's
[__] you Stan moments my dad I would
catch him like he' be on the phone with
his friend Stan like yeah yeah Stan oh
I'd love to help with that yeah could I
oh that's great yeah what an honor all
right I'll get right on it hangs up goes
[__] you Stan like like gets mad at Stan
that he offered to do something for him
that's so Fu I can super relate to this
because some I am different people at
different times of the week also on my
in my during my Lal phase like I'm just
a completely different person how I view
myself so things I say yes to
enthusiastically I will like I will
[__] hate myself for saying yes to
you two weeks later you guys I solved
this problem like 5 years ago got
pregnant oh no literally me and my my
college friends we did it was like 2017
or whatever we're like this is the year
where no one can flake and on anything
not just with each other but if you
flaked on anything in your life you had
to do a punishment and for us it was
like Drive the other one to the airport
or something like you know cross town
whatever and every time I said yes to
plans I was like am I really going to do
this or else I'm going to be punished
and that just got into my system and now
I don't flake on things and I do not say
yes to things that I'm not going to such
a we actually love that about you it's a
wild thing to watch I never met anyone
that does that like I want to be that
reliable not to anyone else like to
myself cuz I cannot believe sometimes
like who the [__] that person was that
said yes to this cuz I'm like I'd rather
die than go to this like in that moment
I'm like I'd rather [__] die and go
do this and you know what I think like
cuz I love what you guys did but I also
feel like if you could take punishment
out of it so it's like it's more like
focusing on the positive of it like I
really want to do everything I say I
want to do which is what you guys get to
but it's like cuz I feel like I punish
myself so much anyway it's like I want
to do more like just like in cabala they
say I can't remember what it's called
but it's like so it's all about when you
say something that agree to do something
you're doing it like to be like a part
of a light and not for the other person
or for like there can't be any ulterior
motives in it even if you're doing it
just to like look good or to make
someone else feel better yeah I think
for me it's just like consequences work
yeah consequences work for me by the way
when I finally do go to that thing and I
hate the thing that I really didn't want
I do enjoy it always always I'm glad I
did this always feel do you think it's
like it's because of the follow through
you're getting the dopamine of like no
it's because it's not as terrible as I
built it up in my head but also like
it's the social anxiety of it all of
being like Oh I have to hold
conversation I have to do you feel like
you have to become a different person
when you go into these things I think
it's not a different person it's just
that like like I've been reading this
book it's like I'm a closeted um
introvert oh did I start get excited
what she said she was
positive she perked up but so I can like
like perform in like social situations
so I think that's what it is it's like
my true authentic self is very like
quiet and observant and kind of just
like I like to sit at home and
dissociate you know what I mean and so
um when I'm out I do have I don't I'm
not a different person I just have to
turn a side of me on and it takes a lot
of effort oh I have to pretend a lot
really yeah because it's like cuz I just
I'm an introvert like I don't really
like kicking in with a lot of people
like small settings like this that's
perfectly fine we have so many staff I'm
talking about like you know you go to
clubs or all those like [__] venues
like that like I could turn it on you
know what I mean but that took practice
over years and years of practice cuz
normally when I was younger I would just
be on my phone to myself or just talking
to one person that I know so now I was
just like okay you don't like this about
yourself like how do you do this it's
like a game now it's literally a game
like when I talk to somebody I go what's
their humor like what do they find funny
throw them this joke they find it funny
no switch it this way okay they like it
cool and it just becomes this game over
and over and over interest does it keep
it interesting to you kind of yeah
because so my wife she you know she has
a corporate job and she has all these
corporate events like I hate them I
[__] hate that's hard but then I go
in and I go I just tell her you need to
give me like a week heads up cuz I have
to mentally prepare myself to talk to
you can hate her for a whole week [__]
this [__] and I just go in and she goes
everybody loved you I was like yeah cuz
I was trying really hard so ex and then
I go home and I just stare at the
ceiling for like an hour because you're
an Entertainer you're going there and
you entertain people like my dad has the
same thing where he he gets anxiet
doesn't want to go places and I think
it's like your weight the the weight of
having to entertain people is maybe on
you yeah which is such a weird thing to
feel though right like you're just
supposed to be there but then you have
this like feeling of I I wanted these
people to have a good time and then you
try to entertain but you don't want to
do it too much where you come off too
strong so you're just doing like this
weird little balance it is a weird value
like to CU one of my highest values is
like entertaining people too and I try
to not like shame my because it's just
fun I don't know it's just H she is a
freaking like social genius cuz she can
talk to anyone like across the
McDonald's counter at the DMV like I am
friends with my girl at right but her
ability to do very like super deep talk
and then just super small talk is your
range is incredible I try to be really
present in the moment with everyone and
you're quick and you're like just like
you keep things light and I'm like [__]
like Annie you're good at this see that
me and I'd have to be in the Moon yes
same I'd have to be in the perfect move
but what I really what I admire and a
lot of um my favorite people are really
like they do like pranks and stuff so
like I love Sasha Baron Cohen and I love
Nathan Fielder and I love um Ed
Bassmaster who's a YouTuber that do he's
amazing right he's the best but it's
like when I when I meet people like this
and I see them work it's like they what
they do is they go into character so
hard that it can't even like penetrate
them like when I go out and I talk to
people like that I'm I'm pretty
vulnerable because I'm giving like my
exact self to people and I think what
I'm learning is I have to have like a
little bit of a like a little cuz it's
too crazy it's like I get drained and
it's and I give a lot of myself to
people that aren't even like they're
like we didn't want this do you guys
feel and and I want to ask this about
girls too do you feel girls and this is
just like a saying do you feel girls
when they make friendships they kind of
[__] on the first date a little too hard
yes like we went hard we were like
[__] oh cuz I I I see this a lot with
a lot of like girls like throughout my
years right I've seen girls who they see
like a quality that they like in a girl
and they click real hard but they don't
actually know the person and so later on
what'll happen they'll be like I can't
believe this girl did this to me it's
like but you don't know them in my mind
cuz I feel girls definitely do this it's
almost as if like if there if there is
like a kindred feeling like we basically
scissored on our first like 5 Hour
FaceTime or something like that like it
is something that I never really thought
about before cuz I just thought oh if
you find someone that you click with you
just click and that's how it works right
but maybe do girls do this more than
dudes you guys don't do that I don't
think guys guys are a little I'm
generalizing right now so I'm just
saying from my experience right like
guys tend to be a little more weary I
don't know why it's just like who [__]
is this guy usually it's like this like
I'll beat your ass like that's the first
for no [__] reason right and well
maybe you do want to like you want to
assess the threat something like that
then it goes like oh he's kind of cool
hey he kind of funny oh I kind of like
him all right we'll see what's up and
then we kind of just start gradually
hanging out but we kind of at of arms
what about you and girlfriends like
friends women friends like I have a lot
I have more girlfriends than I do guy
friends I know but you [__] too hard on
the first date with the girls no I think
for me and girls like sometimes girls
get exhausting right so it's like I like
how your face is very
telling so like like my wife knows this
right if I'm going to go hang out with a
home girl one-on-one typically it's
usually going to be an emotion Fest and
I'm just there to listen right
so I feel like a lot of lot of guy
friends don't know that they always try
to fix it or I have a lot of guy friends
they would never you try to fix a girl's
problem impossible I want them to but
they never can we don't have the
solution either it's like the like it's
too pragmatic you know what I'm saying
do you feel like that even with your
wife with my wife I don't give her any
advice cuz she'll sock me so I just like
I just kind of like you know you just
have to listen at a certain point
because most people if if you believe
that your friends are smart people they
could figure it out themselves they
probably already have yeah they're just
like they're like seeing need you to
hold space they just need you to listen
at least for me it's like you're right
like I probably know the way out I know
the solution I have my answers I just
like hearing myself say it to someone
helps me process it a little bit better
I also think I have a little bit of a
cheat Cod cuz I grew up in a beauty
supply store so I was around women all
the [__] time you know what I mean
and just [__] yap yap yap yap yap all
the [__] time so I to hear it all the
time so now it's just like oh I get it
they just talking to talk but do you
think it is it a warm feeling for you to
like hear women
like talk because well I like being
around girls too because I feel like
girls can talk about anything you know
what I mean like girls can L chop it
about like like if we're not
romantically involved it's super fun you
know what I mean because but when you
become romantically involved with like
my wife she now is a lot more sensitive
to the things that I say so I can't make
these jokes with her so like I'll for
example when we first started dating I
could make fun of her for [__] days
now if I look at her like dirty ass
knees no mild joke she goes what's wrong
with my
knees I'm like yo what the [__] just
happened right now she's like I was on
my knees earlier for
you I wish no but she just like I have
to be careful with her now because now
we're like emotionally attached to and
you're bound yes so now I had to learn
that I'm like oh I can't joke with her
like I used to because let me call Kila
and get this off yeah let me just call
Kila real quick you cross-eyed [__]
thank you and I just hang up oh God I
feel great you know oh it's really
making me itch to abuse you I'm so sorry
trust me he's bringing out my abuse
side I can actually handle a whole lot
of abuse it's my Baseline and I mean
have I ever had an issue like I threaten
to drown him all the time she does and
I'm very scared of the OD potion I'm
like wait just you [__] wait till
we're close to body water could take you
diving and like tell the fish to come
[__] with you yeah she'd be like no I
have I'll Attack you I have plans to
feed David to the Sharks for like years
do you have like a like a staff you use
when you go down like a queen you think
she's King Triton she's King Triton but
Queen but she has his
back gun I just shoot you it's like so
crazy when we were doing oh you go shoot
it's like that now I just [__] cuz I
made F of your weird ass eyes the [__]
it helps her see the
fish she she's supposed to be in the
water she's not supposed to be on land
the more you [__] swim the more your
eyes go far apart you start becoming a
fish we were doing like on our
Thanksgiving episode we were doing um
like the things that we love about each
other and totally forgot that you're a
[__] woman of the ocean oh thank you
I was thinking about that that you're
just like when people are like where's
Kila I'm like I'm assuming she's
swimming somewhere in the sea in the sea
somewhere some people don't understand
about like making fun of like people
they sometimes don't understand the
concept of you got to make fun of them
for stuff that's not really make funable
right right then it becomes enjoyable
like if somebody has like I don't know
like a weird ailment and like this
mother got cancer you know like it's not
funny but if you call like a pretty girl
ugly and you just joke around like that
I think you could make a person with
cancer laugh I do think that I'm trying
I'm going to S see later you can do it
play like a clown nose know I still have
a video of me where' your eyebrows
go I was doing hip thrusts at the gym
and my God there's a video of David
David basically like for like 30 seconds
being you ugly weak [__] you're so
[__] ugly that's why Bobby broke up
with you just going off and I'm doing
just like really heavy hip thrust did it
help you work yes I was trying to
motivate her yeah listen we know your
origin
story I need to get beat she always has
like this weird taste in men and I was
telling her like there's a couple of
when when they broke up there's a couple
of guy friends asking like yo is she
single like no no you cannot handle it
no no no okay oh my God okay so he has a
friend of his who is allegedly the
nicest guy on Earth and David doesn't
think I should date him no puss has
fangs that's why I don't think so are
you nuts I'm not ucing you to him he's a
really good guy he's a you out of your
[__] mind what do you think is going
to happen you're just you just you're
just not for him I think but I like but
now is it because he won't let you have
him let him try me that's the thing
you're G to chew him upid let me let him
try no no no no he's also this guy too
let him hit it he doesn't have a strong
enough personal she would run over him
so easy he would like start to mold his
personality and his humor to match her
and then he's going you're like er kabad
you know what I'm saying everybody she
touches she just [__] up you know what
I mean that's who you are anybody in
this room I couldn't introduce anybody
to him he would just Kila and Katie are
both like they're both Scorpios I which
I I don't know what it is but it's the
same thing with Katie I'm like if these
two get together they could
destroy this is what I'm saying would
you introduce Esther or Annie to your
friend no so none of us no but that's
like look strong personality right very
strong personality strong personality
this guy is malleable oh he sounds good
I know
I'm not doing it she likes to sculpt I
know I got stuck with a guy that is not
sculptable and it is the best it is
actually the best yeah do would you
respect the guy that you could just get
him to do whatever you want though I
think that the answer is no I don't know
cuz I've never had that because but it's
always been my dream but I I feel like
there's no way that that's sustainable
you just get I just not attractive like
I I didn't like so I was with one girl
that I didn't we had ultimately broke up
not because she was terrible is because
anything I said she would agree with
even if she didn't believe in it and I
hated it cuz it's like I'm never going
to get to know you right there's going
to be moments where we have to go back
and forth on a not all the time right
but if I say and there would be stuff
that after I thought about it I was
wrong and that I would apologize to her
be like hey I'm sorry that I think I was
completely wrong and then she goes no
you're right I'm like I [__] hate
this you know yeah you don't want to I
think there is no you will not grow as a
couple or individually if you're in a
Yes Man relationship it's just
impossible you need someone to push back
security it's like it's it's like
immature it's not well she's also
thinking like oh if I become an
agreeable person this person won't leave
me yeah he'll like me better and then
that's you feel that neediness and
you're like yeah it was just weird right
cuz I felt like oh I'm with this I've
been with the stranger for six months
you know because anything I say you'll
agree with even if I'm wrong and if I I
don't get to reconcile my my feelings
because I was wrong and I need to
apologize if you guys were doing like
the newly game her her thing would just
have an arrow to your answer whatever he
says she just cop copies my vows but
that does as a woman like sound so
relaxing to just be like I have I have
known of my own thoughts this whatever
he says like there is something about
that that I
like I don't so I go brain dead when I'm
65 maybe but I think my brain is a
little bit too active right now and
cares about too many things to have like
a total yes man but maybe when I'm tired
and I just want a [__] nap all day
like I would want that I just never want
to go at it again in a relationship
where it's like you're always like
fighting to be right it's like that's so
just draining and then you're fighting
so much it's like it just doesn't even
one of you just has to be like let's
just there's those stages though right
like in the beginning it's like the
infatuation stage and then you start
getting to a little arguments and you're
fighting all the [__] time and if you
go over this hump then you could usually
make it after cuz that that stage where
we were just yelling at each other I
hated it but it's so important I learned
in therapy like when Bobby and I did um
couples's therapy
that the one thing apparently that we
didn't do enough we didn't know how to
fight and because we didn't know how to
fight we didn't know how to negotiate
our needs you guys never fought no
hardly ever um we were just two people
that grew up in very like high conflict
homes so we avoided it at all cost and
so we would just kind of stuff it and we
you know like we're very like
antagonistic on the podcast when like
the mics are on but at home like in our
real life we were just very like it was
Harmony a lot of times aside from the
fact but it wasn't right I I was angry
about a lot of things that he wasn't
meeting and he was probably the same way
but we didn't know how to negotiate
because we didn't fight yes that was
that was when we first started dating
early on she was somebody who says I
don't yell I don't fight right which I'm
like you're Korean [__] right so she
would do this thing where she would say
she wasn't angry but her actions were
very angry right so it' be like oh
passor salt all right and she'll scrape
it across the table and then that would
piss me off even more cuz clearly you're
mad but CU she'll smile and she'll be
like I'm not angry and that just makes
you know the vein starts coming out so
we were doing this hike and I was fat as
[__] at this time and so that's why she
wants to get up earlier she like don't
get fat again so we were hiking it was
early on a relationship and she just
books it and I'm just walking alone with
my fat ass self and I'm like yo what the
[__] so she does the whole hike and
comes back and she goes where were you
I'm like hey this is a couple's hike
we're together you just left me and I
don't know where I'm going I'm not a
hiker I'm like free food out here are
you nuts and so I'm pissed and we get
into the car I was like I don't like
that you did that we're doing couple
[__] you did that the last time when we
went biking you dusted my ass like you
were in Tron and I was [__] alone
biking by myself and you did it again
and I don't like it and she goes I don't
understand why you're mad and I was like
okay that makes me even more mad I was
like and then she goes I'm not angry I'm
like you're angry you're upset she goes
I'm not angry and I snapped I was like
if you don't express something to me I
I'm [__] done with this [__] and she
takes a pause she looks at me and she
goes what the [__] do you want from me
at the top of her lungs I peed a little
bit cuz it scared the living [__] out of
me and this was like our fourth fourth
or third month together she's never
raised her voice and so when I heard
that [__] after that Pandora's Box was
open yeah all yelling all the time now
and I kind of regret it just a little
bit but because of that I love assault
show she started screaming and yelling
and then after that I was like oh this
so she's for real pissed you know and I
started getting to know her a little
more but once we got over that hump and
was just way calm yeah yeah I think that
I mean imagine if it' been like 3 four
years in and she still hadn't like
yelled like I don't think that would
she'd probably have like all gray hairs
turn into a cancer at some point yeah
some people don't have to yell but they
could still Express themselves she
couldn't do either right that's that
really is a hard thing though because
like I when I'm super emotional like I
get I I can't get the words out I can't
formulate sentences but have you and
Dave or you and Todd ever had like bad
screaming matches like that kind of
fight he's not not a voice raiser that's
like good it's like not an option yeah
Todd's not either it's like I've tried
like when I the relationship I left to
when I before the relationship I got out
of before I got into it with Todd was so
screamy like like neighbors threatening
to call the cops like so bad and so I
still had that like residual you know
that person's like still in you and um
that you were with that with the other
guy and so I like I tried and he
wouldn't get mad and then I would just
go go go and be like is this what you
want and I was like no sorry yeah no I'm
sorry no and now it's like if I raise my
voice which is like literally once a
year with him like and it's always over
something I didn't assert myself with
calmly earlier and it's never really him
it's just something I didn't like get
forth I didn't like say strong enough
for myself and then I get mad he gets
really quiet and I it just isn't the
it's not the route yeah yelling thing
too is like you know when you grow up in
a house where everybody yells and breaks
[__] that's like your norm and so she we
had this moment too where I this was
years ago we got really [__] angry
and then she had like this little eye
cream and I was like [__] this I threw
it and then she started crying why did
you throw it though why the eye cream
cuz it was so tiny and I wanted to throw
something but I didn't want it to be
disastrous so I found something really
small the we need the I what the hell
and they're expensive how many
girlfriends do you have obviously not
I chucked her little eye cream and then
she started crying I'm like what are you
crying about she goes well I don't feel
comfortable around you cuz you're
throwing things and I'm like IE cream I
was like it's so small and she goes it
doesn't matter you broke something in
front of me and that scares me after
that I never did it again cuz in my mind
I was like wait my mom threw a rice
cooker at my dad's head so we're kind of
no my family was throwy yeah but you
just don't break things in general well
it's just so scary too and then it's so
embarrassing after you breaks isn't it
so embarrassing when you let
embarrassing oh my God I never did it
since and imagine and you think about
when you have kids like doing that in
front of them is just so unacceptable
those are those moments where I look at
myself and I go oh this wasn't healthy
just because you grew up with it doesn't
mean that it's right and I haven't done
it since then the one time I threw
something it was a it was a puff jacket
and it just puffed in the air and it
pissed me off even more cuz it it was it
wasn't stress relieving and I just threw
this windbreaker it just went up [__] it
floated down the [__] my dad went to
anger management classes when we were
kids and he came came back there was
like two weeks where he was told to
squeeze a towel and countdown from 10 he
was just squeezing all the he just had
like a towel on his shoulder all day
squeezing it was so funny wait does that
that sounds like it really works it does
because I think you do feel Ridiculous
by the end of it and then my my mom uh
and dad took like a course together and
they said that you just start talking in
nonsense like you just start doing like
a dumb voice or something when you're in
to fight and then it breaks it cuz it's
so ridiculous but that got a little
weird do you have to solve do you guys
have to to solve when you fight with
your partners like in the moment or do
you have to separate and come back it
depends it depends what it's about like
I find that um sometimes I really need
to take a beat and get the [__] out of
there because like you know I grew up in
like a you know rice cooker to the Head
household and so like even though I'm
very like oh take the path of least
resistance there are times where I'm so
[__] mad that I'm like oh that old me
could come out right now yes I need to
take a beat but then I think that the
responsibility is on me to come back and
not wait for them to like chase me if
I'm the one leaving it is my
responsibility to come back and then
broach the the conversation again those
are really like hard conversations to
have with the partner too cuz this girl
that I was dating she we ultimately
broke up because she would keep poking
at me to make me mad how so like like I
would give clear boundaries like CU I
went through anger management as a kid
cuz I was so [__] angry cuz I you
grew up around it and so I would tell
her hey when I tell you I need space I
need you to walk away from me like just
get away she goes no I don't want I
don't want to I'm going to be right here
and she just get in my face my M my dad
yeah and then I snapped and I yelled
like an inch away from her face and I
screamed at the top of my lungs and then
she got really quiet and then we got out
the car I looked at her I was like we're
done and she's like why and I'm like
because you make me into a person that I
never wanted to be it's like this person
that I saw myself yelling at a person
that I care about is never the person I
wanted to be and I just yelled at a
woman and I'm twice your size what kind
of man am I now so it's like you make me
that and she wasn't supporting your
growth and your anger like she wasn't
supporting you like working through your
anger and giving the boundary and stuff
and I told her about my anger issues as
a kid all this other stuff she's like no
when we solve it we have to solve it now
but I'm like I don't ever want to be a
guy that is with his partner and then
just screams at them in Rage because I
sometimes you need to cool you need some
cool off you do but it's very hard for
an anxiously attached partner to watch
someone walk away cuz it feels as though
they're never coming back right cuz I
used to be that that way like like now
I'm the person that needs a little bit
of space but there have been times where
I've had Partners like that who are like
I need a moment and I'm like no we
should be able to discuss it right here
right now and they really just need a
moment but I couldn't figure out why
they need I was also afraid that if they
close that door they left that they're
not coming back that they're going to
realize that they actually don't want
this that they're going to have enough
time to think that or to to real they're
going to have 10 minutes to realize that
they actually want to break up and that
terrified me so I'm like please don't
leave please don't leave like let's work
it out now we had in coup's therapy this
one lesson like years ago where she was
like if someone needs to walk away you
need the rule is you're allowed to do
that but you have to say when you're
coming back yes so it's like I'll be
back in 30 whatever it is as long as the
other person knows when you're coming
back I like that cut tell us like
looking at the
clock crying yeah [__] go right now the
other thing that me and Dave tomato
timer this thing that me and Dave like
made up that we've been doing for like
literally 10 years is if someone says
something and it feel feels a little
nasty the other person goes tone and
then they have to like resay it a little
bit nicer and then it's like it's it
kind of like makes us both like mad and
laugh and it just keeps it from
escalating so instead of if you give me
a mean tone instead of me giving you a
mean tone back I can just go tone and
then you have to like be nicer I just
say though can I just say if I'm in the
peak of my rage and someone said tone I
would never sayone to you I'd be like
you want to [__] your tone sayone I
think but I think you guys are so much
healthier and more communicative but I
think that like when my rage bubbles
over like there's almost nothing you can
say that's correct I just need to get
the [__] away yeah yeah yeah yeah um I
think that is good that is really good
for in the before things in the early
stages
sometimes we be like that wasn't a tone
you know angry you need to do tone on
your tone I think of like when I give
when I give Randy treats you know I make
him sit and then I want him to lay down
the lay down he's like like he doesn't
want to do the lay down but then he does
and gets his treat so it's like I feel
like ton is like that where it's like
your oh this is a dog I thought you were
talking about the guy you're with oh
[__] I was like yo this is kind of toxic
Todd would Todd would do it Todd would
do
Todd this is such a good episode I'm
having such a good time I know David you
need to come back I'm one of the girls D
I know but you like you're leading the
girl part yes yeah I like girl talk I
know it feels David's one of my best
girlfriends I'm telling you man she
tampons all that other [__] D let's go
um David where can people find more of
you you have like three podcasts yeah so
Gilbert and me Gilbert and my our buddy
Nick started an MMA podcast called uh oh
[__] the casuals Oh I thought called oh
[__] I was like this is the second time
be forgotten it today I know it's I
don't know it's the casuals MMA and then
you could check me out on genius brain
podcast and also dudes behind the foods
yeah oh wait this is where we forgot we
didn't tap into David so they Nam
dropped me at Asian restaurants and I
was like I'm not the person to name drop
it's him I do have a little pool with
Asian restaurants oh I'm just always
like I'm like if I wait long enough
they're going to remember my head next
to
kila's no but I'm telling you guys
David's the guy and not even just Asian
restaurants like all restaurants cuz
he's like like he's a fcy food guy he
was on a food show on Netflix and
everything not very fancy I eat I like
looking for the cheapest Foods possible
that taste really good speaking Esther's
language over here you really are old
Chinese person dude yeah I know when you
asked if Dave was I was like that kind
of rings true for Esther yeah you're a
little you're a little
weird little [__] weird out there I
like it thank you so much David come
back anytime let me know I'm right
around the corner oh and we're supposed
to say Merry Christmas right I had I
already had this and it's a medium and I
don't know if it's going to fit your
shoulders and I don't know if it's going
to fit your belly but I have one I
should get I'll get a third but
it's I don't know who it's for I'll just
show you what it is I'll show you what
it
is your shoulders I love that [__] it's
oh my God I have one of these yeah it is
car a little doggy I'll oh my God I'll
take it cuz I have Remy yes you can
bring Remy in it so much isn't it so
cute it's a hoodie that has a little
doggy pouch you see it I'm like es
already has a I have actually like two
of these I am so sorry I've had a tissue
to my face this whole time I'm glad you
took it out your nose CU I was having
trouble yeah are you sure my yeah it was
making your eyes Focus um thank you so
much for joining us check out David so
wherever you can and we'll see you next
week with a brand new episode for our
holiday December
celebration
[Music]
oh